this is maybe the closest fall i've ever
done
look how beautiful two minutes oh my god
oh my god here we go
hey guys it's kelly and today i've been
challenged to make a classic
steakhouse dinner in only 20 minutes
i've never done this before
i have no idea if it's gonna work but
i'm really up for the challenge all
right
start the clock let's go all right first
thing i'm turning on my heat i need to
get it super hot to sear my steak
next up i have some yukon gold potatoes
that i'm going to dice
to make mashed potatoes if you're a
little worried why didn't peel it
don't worry about it you can actually
eat the skin on these potatoes they're
super thin
they mash right up and they add some
flavor and texture
so i'm chopping these about half inch
dice just so they cook quicker
i'm going to be doing this in an instant
pot they hold up really well
to the cooking process and are easy to
mash
okay into the instant pot
now a little bit of water so they don't
burn on the bottom
and of course season the salt
okay see if our pot is hot i'm adding
canola oil
next up we're going to season these
beautiful steaks
it's just a new york strip boneless so
it cooks a little bit quicker
tons of salt freshly ground black pepper
both sides
okay and we're using canola oil because
it has a higher smoke point and it won't
burn when we're searing our steaks so
i'm going to add them in away from me
into the pan
all right and let those cook for about
three to four minutes per side and in
the meantime
i'm going to start chopping some
shallots i don't know what i was
thinking when i
picked this menu i was really trying to
go a little crazy making an entire
steakhouse dinner
in 20 minutes is kind of crazy okay i'm
just thinly slicing the shallot
so it cooks quicker a little bit better
if i was doing this the traditional way
without like an insta pot
a microwave for dessert it would
probably take close to an hour
definitely
these stoves these burners are like not
heating up
but i knew that going into it because
we're working with electric so
move on to my next step i'm gonna heat
some cream and butter and garlic
to fold into our mashed potatoes when
it's time
i'm taking three huge garlic chunks and
just
smashing them
this is going to help infuse a ton of
garlic flavor in our potatoes
and of course you need butter so we'll
just put that on a low heat to simmer
just to let all that garlic infuse while
the potatoes are cooking
i'm saving half of the shallot to baste
my steaks with when the time comes
next up i'm going to grate some garlic
into this for our cream spinach
i personally hate chopping garlic and i
just think this is an easier
quicker way to get all that garlic
flavor without having garlic all over
your hand
how much time do we have 14
where did six minutes just go he
seasoned my shallots so
salt season every way every step of the
way you need to season your dishes
is this on okay well i guess i'll move
on to
dessert since that's taking forever
we're making microwave lava cakes i
should tell you
so we're starting with a cake mix just
any chocolate cake then i'm adding a
quarter cup of applesauce and what this
is going to do is add a ton of moisture
and flavor without adding a ton of fat
and then a little bit of water
just whisk this together
check mistakes oh look at that
look how beautiful perfect okay
let him cook on the other side my
instant pot is stealing up to pressure
i'm a little worried but there's nothing
i can do about it now
okay so now that this is all mixed up
i'm going to divide it in between
two mugs
and then to make it a lava like cake i'm
adding a truffle in the middle of each
one
and it will create that ooey gooey
chocolate center that you're used to
seeing
in a lava cake so i'm gonna put these in
the microwave for about a minute
oh my salads got a little too burnt but
nobody's gonna know
adding my spinach
all right well we'll come back to that
i'm gonna add some butter
to our skillet some salad some garlic
and some thyme
okay spinach
i'll go more slowly this time i got 10
minutes and that's still not up to
pressure
okay that's cookie i'm gonna baste our
steaks
with all that beautiful butter and
infused flavors
check our cakes maybe a little longer
i'm nervous i'm i'm starting to get
nervous i just feel spinach all over the
floor my nerves have obviously gotten
the best of me
but i have no choice i have to keep
going okay it's up to pressure okay good
now it's gonna take six minutes to cook
and then not leave me with three and a
half minutes
to mash the potatoes these burners suck
i don't know what else to say all right
i'm just waiting for this spinach to
cook down
okay five minutes left on the instant
pot
i don't have much more time i don't know
i don't know
okay steaks are done
let them rest a little bit back to the
spinach
who knew spinach was gonna be the
disaster in all this
this is the easiest thing to make so i'm
just trying to cook the spinach to get
all the water out because we're making
cream spinach and we don't want it to be
water we want it to be almost like a
bechamel
so i'm just using a colander to strain
all that liquid out because we
don't want it seven minutes oh my where
does the time go
it was just a nine and a half all right
i'm feeling the pressure can you tell
do i look nervous well at least
dessert's done
it needs to be plated potatoes are
cooking steak is resting
getting all the water out trying not to
burn my hand because it's super hot
if you had more time normally you would
let this cool for like 10 minutes so
you're not burning your hand
but hey it's gonna be the game
okay adding some cream
i'm gonna add some cream cheese to
really thicken it up
and some parmesan
instant pot has two minutes i have 5 45.
this is looking great let's just see if
it tastes great i honestly think we
could do more cream cheese
more salt maybe a little more cream
cheese
five minutes okay okay let's see where
we're at let's see
okay i still have to mash the potatoes i
have to cut the steak
and garnish my cakes
yes yes okay this is done
this is done i just have to plate it
once this is done um
releasing all the pressure i will mash
the potatoes
for now i will garnish our cakes
okay dessert's done creamed spinach
done
open okay i won't cut the steak yet i
want to do it at the last minute so that
all the juices get to recollect into the
meat
so i'm just waiting just maybe
come on come on well i'll plate this
garnish with a little more parmesan
cause why not
okay come on block shut
okay i gotta cut the steak so i can mash
the potatoes
this is maybe the closest fall i've ever
done
do it oh my god okay
i feel like i'm manhandling this steak
a little more salt why the heck not
oh okay i'm gonna have like 30 seconds
to mashed potatoes
i better get ready two minutes oh my god
oh my god okay
guys this thing's gonna kill me i'll
tell you what these are gonna be some
chunky
mashed potatoes oh yes
okay
draining draining draining
okay all right here we go
this thing is so hot so hot
okay remember what i said these are
gonna be some chunky
mashed potatoes it's the only choice i
have
one minute oh my gosh oh my god here we
go
okay i really apologize
to all the chefs out there because i'm
being messy
as hell but i have no time how many
seconds how many seconds 40 seconds okay
i just can't leave a mess okay
i have no idea how these taste but i
have to go i have to go
30 seconds okay
okay okay okay okay it's not the
prettiest thing i've ever made that's
for sure
but i did it i did it
i did it uh it's it's not as pretty as i
wanted but
i did it and i cannot believe it oh my
god
[Music]
so i just finished cooking a steak
dinner in 20 minutes
i honestly feel like i blacked out i
don't know what just happened but
there's food in front of me so i
obviously made something it's not as
pretty as i'd like i really like to take
my time with plating but
you saw i literally had 30 seconds to
plate things so it is what it is it's
time to dig in so let's see how this all
tastes
first up steak
the steak is really well seasoned it has
an awesome char
on the outside but i definitely
overcooked it to be honest i kind of
forgot about it i wish it was a little
more rare but
what can you do let's try the cream
spinach i feel like cream spinach is
either like
you either love it or hate it it's like
very polarizing
okay that's amazing you can't go wrong
with cream cheese heavy cream and
parmesan
i personally like spinach so i love this
super decadent it was really good for
the amount of
stress and anxiety these potatoes gave
me
they better be delicious so let's see
these are so good you can really taste
that garlic that i infused in the heavy
cream
and i really don't even mind the skin on
them alright and last up
dessert i can see the chocolate pooling
in the bottom oh my god
can you see it it worked it's like
dripping out it's perfect
the cake is amazing it's super rich and
decadent and it has that really fun
effect
overall i'm pretty impressed with myself
after tasting it
because i wasn't really tasting as i go
i think i'd give myself an 8 out of 10
on this one
alright well that is about it i can't
believe i did it but i made a classic
steakhouse dinner
in under 20 minutes if you guys want to
try this challenge at home
all the recipes are on tasty.com stay
tuned for more 20 minute challenges on
tasty
i'm kelly and i'll see you later oh
yes
[Music]
[Music]
you